[Musique]
il faut c'est dit c'est que dit la fille
c'est baptiste rémy blot ford qui me
saute
sa fidélité aux vidéos c'est
la
pénalité
c'est beau c'est ici j'y ai passé ces
coeurs
nos comportements intimes aux écoles
mais au meeting départemental
cassano
face jusqu'à louis thomas thomas
pour que vos séances à une musique l
essai qui gonfle
mais déjà
finaliste un bété %
photographe écossais
la mia rolleiflex
et belhocine aux migrants aidés
[Musique]
ainsi de mieux
théo majorque il faut c'est pas dit
qu'on travaille ou procès passons
musique ne sais pas
et de la fina photo du pays combattent
pas
près de dix finales des
[Musique]
jo à odile berthod est né dans l'état de
bahia brésil il a fait ses études dans
la capitale de cet état salvador on voit
que les dieux de la chanson veiller sur
lui et multiplier les symboles joao
gilberto est né en 1931 si nos calculs
sont bons il est en âge d'être croulants
c'est pourtant lui l'authentic inventeur
de la bossa nova en écoutant zhao
gilberto on serait tenté de dire il vaut
mieux s'adresser à dieu qu'à ses saints
et aux créateurs condisciples car zhao
gilberto possède une originalité un
tempérament que l'on est bien heureux de
rencontrer chez un spécialiste de cette
musique généralement si peu cheap et que
l'on appelle typique
[Musique]
qui dit il
linkedin ces femmes allaitent en lice fo
bail chez les hommes le préfet de vie
vacances aussi mort sont de la merde
mais violent
à 10
[Musique]
km
sous la mer toute violence
[Musique]
il a bossé missouri
kojima conseil system makhzenique
[Musique]
qui me disait